it's an emotional time in my life for
sure we have a good time together he's
just really sweet cue the wedding bells
Halley and Justin Bieber are gearing up
to walk down the aisle and we've got
everything you need to know he's a good
kid it's a good part and I love him
Haley celebrated her bachelorette bash
on Wednesday night she's stunned in all
white and yeah those are definitely
penis straws you're looking at even
though we had to blur them stylist may
Riley posted and this boomerang of Haley
and Kendall Jenner though it's since
been deleted meanwhile Justin enjoyed
boys night skateboarding with pals
[Music]
nothing but good clean fun I'm here for
it as for the wedding itself it's
seemingly happening this weekend yeah
you heard that right in South Carolina
and a source tells et it'll be the event
of their lives
of course the couple has been legally
married since last September but our
source says they want to celebrate their
love and unity in front of the people
they love especially God which by the
way I love I believe it's not my job to
push anything that I believe on anyone
else you know I think it's just my job
to be a light and share what I've been
what I went through as far as my
spiritual my spiritual journey our store
says they want their wedding to be
private and an all-around party for
their loved ones Justin has been very
open about the love he and Hailey share
posting this pic earlier this month
with a caption quote better at 70 baby I
love you more every day you challenge me
strengthen me and your overall way
cooler and more awesome than I am and
I'm okay with that
I mean could they be any cuter the pair
has been especially adorable on
Instagram lately though playing with
their new cats together doing laundry
together and they spent Labor Day at the
beach so cute all I know is I cannot
wait to see these wedding pics everyone
here ET is wishing them both well and
for all the latest on jelly make sure
you keep it locked right here until next
time I have Katie Krauss and bye for now
you